talk yourself up and perhaps get some
professional head shots with makeup on
your face so you look roughly 3 to 4
years younger if I was a dude I would
totally use Photoshop I'm sorry all the
women they all use the filters they all
use the makeup if I was a dude on a
dating app with the amount of lying that
women do I would just even the playing
field I say make it even guys go for it
I would I would lie I would lie about my
age I would lie about
everything what up guys welcome to the
just things YouTube channel today I am
going to be reacting to a mgtow channel
uh for those of you that don't know
mgtow is men going their own way and I
personally I think mgtow guys really get
a bad rep they always characterize them
as these guys that just don't get women
but really I would say that mgtow are
men that want to go their own way
because of the systems that have been
built in society by feminism but before
I start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos um first and foremost um
a like is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so let's try to get to 1,000 likes on
this video um okay so This Is 40 plus
women let's see what the mtow guys have
to say about dating women over 40 years
old all right everyone s man here this
video is brought to you by a donation
from Paul and here's what he has to say
hey Sandman I'm about to hit the big
five go it's harder to date women in
their 30s even with money here in Boston
it's like the only women looking at me
now are 40 and above I'm not badl
looking and I'm actually 6'2 which helps
but I don't want to date women over 40
because they're used up basket
cases what advice would you give to
someone like myself that still likes to
date and sleep with women but won't use
hookers and doesn't actually want women
under 40 thank you well Paul thanks for
your donation as well as your topic
request I'm surprised it's taken this
long for this to happen to you most
theen women around here want guys that
are at most 5 years older than them and
they actually salivate over younger guys
there's so many issues with women over
the age of 40 as well emotional damage
from seeing more action than a toilet
seat the moodiness and heart and this is
the thing all the women will get so mad
they'll be like oh I can think of this I
am so tired of hearing about exceptions
guys I know 40 plus year old women that
are great but let's call a spade a spade
the majority not great you know I did um
a video called I've red flags in women
it was the most basic things you know
don't date women with multiple baby
daddies and it was so funny I heard this
panel of women reacting to it they're
like oh well I know somebody who who it
would be a great mom what about the ones
that were married twice and it just
didn't work out what so you think number
three is going to work out just from a
data point of view and this is the thing
if a woman's over 35 I'm pretty sure her
chance of getting married I have to look
this up but it's like it it drops the
older she gets indicating that maybe the
older women aren't aren't the best
choice you know um it's not to say there
aren't women with that are good choices
over 40 but the majority n nki notada of
early menopause perhaps dealing with
kids and if she hasn't had kids yet and
it's still over 40 there's a delusion
going around that she can still get
pregnant up until the age of 50 that
seems to be the really big theme in
women that I've spoken to over 40 they
try to boost their self-confidence by
thinking that they can actually still
give birth until the age of 50 um yeah
and it's pure delusion it is pure
delusion to think that you are going to
get pregnant over the age of 40 it's
just the odds aren't in your favor are
there exceptions yes but I am so tired
of hearing the exceptions why can't we
talk about the rule before we talk about
exceptions it's just killing if she does
she'll probably give birth to Rainman
with Down Syndrome their looks are gone
and they're generally crazier than a
duffel bag full of cats most of them are
on some form of medic ation for their
mental health or of some other form of
physical health problems women over 40
are just as delusional as the younger
ones and they think they're all that in
a bag of chips while it's true that both
men and women get emotional damage and
physical damage as we get older men to
certain extent actually deal with those
things better as we age so long as we
still have money and utility value the
typical issues that women complain about
when it comes to men include that he's
pissed off at all women because his ex
screwed him over and he's basically a
financial loser those are the biggest
complaints so if you're a financial
winner even if you're only pretending
not to have any issues with women then
you're in a good position to pump and
dump but realistically who wants a woman
after her mid to late 30s as she ages
sex for her becomes a chore her
moodiness is unbearable along with her
nagging and you as a man probably still
have the same or similar interest with
regards to sex so Paul you probably have
an overactive penis that probably only
feeds only blondes under the age of 40
so unless you're willing to pay for your
meals without an escort you might
actually find yourself out of luck but
as you mentioned that's not an option
perhaps work out and get an expensive
car and that will keep the 35 to 40
crowd still knocking at your door talk
yourself up and perhaps get some
professional head shot with makeup on
your face so you look roughly 3 to 4
years younger get your haircut short if
it isn't and keep it that way which will
pretty much make you look younger as
well exfoli if I was a dude I would
totally use Photoshop I'm sorry all the
women they all use the filters they all
use the makeup if I was a dude on a
dating app with the amount of lying that
women do I would just even the playing
field I swear to God I would I would I
would say I'm 6'2 even if I wasn't I
would say I make more money I'd lie
about my I would lie about everything
because I have seen the catfishing
photos that women use nowadays and I am
sorry and I'll see it firsthand on my
show a girl will come on my show and
I'll look at her Instagram and I'm like
I just saw you ma'am you do not look
like that so it's like you know if the
women are doing this I say make it even
guys go for it I would I would would lie
I would lie about my age I would lie
about everything because at this point
and I know all the the the moral High
Ground people are like you know what you
shouldn't do that just cuz everyone else
is well you know when 80% when women
find 80% of men is unattractive women
find 80% of men is ugly not just okay
not decent ugly it's like can you blame
them for cheating when the women they
started they started the men were not
asking it's like okay let's let's start
Botox lip fillers um I don't know some
Instagram filter now we have shapewear
it's like we're we're cheating left and
right and like everyone comes at me
because I'm not I don't wear a lot of
makeup D but it's like sorry I'd rather
get what I get rather than wear a face
full of makeup and he doesn't recognize
you the next day okay and if the women
are doing that I say lie I say lie like
crazy your skin and maybe also get a tan
you have the option of plastic surgery
you could still still by yourself
another 5 to 10 I wouldn't do the leg
extensions though I think that's too far
for the guys I wouldn't I I understand I
I would just get jacked that age bracket
if you're willing to put in the effort
that might also give you enough time to
accept that your ability to crack open
under 40 vagina will be completely gone
soon even with all your enhancements
it's just something that you need to
accept so you ask me what to do at this
point and that's my best answer Paul do
what women do purchase goods and
services that will make you look younger
than you really are some point you won't
be that's what I said I said they do yes
to have what you actually want anymore
and you have to make peace with that the
thing that really bothers me the most
about women as they get older is their
attitude especially the women that are
more educated and career-driven they
seem to believe that it's their
prerogative to treat men poorly just
because they're so-called educated and
informed the Athenians were right when
they said there's no point to educating
women because it's like giving a snake
more Venom to use against men I found
that the length of the relationships in
my adult life were often connected back
to how much education the woman had the
less educated they were the longer the
relationships lasted and vice versa most
the women no Okay the reason educated
women are crazy is because they
literally put Marxism in the schools so
they basically give you feminism 101
classes and they put them in the school
so the longer the women are in these
feminism classes like gender studies
even I swear to God I was in an
economics class and the teacher was
trying to make it like the rich people
are mean I SW I swear I swear on my I
swear I swear all right she was saying
that the people in the rich
neighborhoods the prices were lower in
rich neighborhoods and she was like
that's cuz the the business owners are
so mean this idiot oh my gosh I I was
fuming this day because because I know I
know about operating like I know people
that run Walmarts and you know why the
Walmarts are less expensive or are more
expensive in poor neighborhoods because
they steal and that raises the price of
everything but no it's just the mean
business or they have to hire security
because they tend to be higher crime but
no but see it's like now we have these
teachers was it a what what was it a
woman teaching this like moral compass
about economics I studied economics so
they go to the schools and they just get
so indoctrinated and it's just poor me
feminism feminism feminism recently that
I've met in their 30s all have one or
two degrees and have the most terrible
attitude that you can imagine this isn't
something that is exclusive to older
women but keep it in mind that if you
meet a woman over 40 and for some crazy
reason you're interested in her and
she's educated then you actually might
want to chalk that up in the negative
column worldly intelligence in women
appears to have a reverse correlation to
their attitude the more education the
worse they are to be around yeah okay
I'm sorry I'm you know maybe and look it
guys does this mean every woman no so
I'm tired of all the women saying oh oh
you're you're so mean it's not every
woman but but I'll tell you this I I got
my masters here because I wanted to play
volleyball and I'm telling you the girls
in these programs they're nuts
especially psychology this is coming
maybe this is a hypocritical because I'm
getting a psychology degree but I'm
telling you the women in these programs
absolutely nuts crazy they're just
indoctrinating like how how to anal
psycho analyze your
ex-boyfriend all this it's like
literally and especially the beware of
girls that are obsessed with narcissists
there is a reason they're obsessed with
and they talk about narcissistic
Tendencies I swear it's usually the most
narcissistic women that are obsessed
with narcissists because if you're
constantly dating narcissists you might
be one I'm not I'm just gonna it might
be you I don't know call me crazy it's
like if you date narcissist narcissist
narcissist to the point where you want
to like what what would make you so
interested in narcissists oh oh the fact
that you've dated some anyway so my
point is this that's true they get
crazier the older the more educated
there's exceptions I'd like to say there
are exceptions but that does not
disprove the rule the less education and
the more simple their thought process
the more pleasant they seem to be around
the way I see it women are like big
children the last thing you need is a
smartass kid telling you what she thinks
just think about that annoying kid that
knows it all and basically no one likes
someone like one of those spoiled kids
from Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
another thing that I've noticed from a
few women that I've actually known
through their 20s 30s and eventually
getting into their 40s is they tend to
have a midlife crisis the way that men
do as well sometimes if they were
somewhat rational at a younger age then
the rationality flies out the window and
they try to live the experiences they
never had if they didn't ride the
Carousel in their 20s and 30s then
suddenly they want to do it in their 40s
oh my gosh I interviewed a woman who
basically said women start to lose it in
their 40s if they've lived a life of
non-submission to their husbands and I
actually I was thinking about this and I
think it's true because if you're not
submissive that means you're like
arguing against everything maybe not in
the beginning but you you know women we
push boundaries it kind of gets like
that so it's like I I do think women
like if you've lived a life of being
crazy it kind of starts to catch up to
you in your 40s cuz one you don't have
Beauty as much anymore so you can't
really like cop out with that and two
it's like habits defined you so Define
you so if you have a habit of you know
submitting to No Authority structure uh
you know I just think it catches up to
you often times because many of them
still can get hit on by guys in their
20s and 30s even if it's only for sexual
reasons it's so easy for older women to
live out their fantasies and have a
younger guy because it's so easy for her
to get such a guy in the first place I
know women in their late 30s and early
40s that only now actually want men in
their 20s they think those guys like
them for who they are and not what they
are but women at that age are on board
time and their bodies are going to fall
apart at any moment they just aren't
aware of it yet they're about to enter
menopause yet at the same time they act
like they're in their 20s because they
never really grow up no okay this th
okay sometimes I look at the Kardashians
okay because and I'll Think Like These
are mother this is a mother of four in
her 40s and I'll look at the way that
she dresses and acts these are the moms
of Our Generation now again not all not
all I know not all but there's a whole
group of women in their 40s that act
like teenagers and it's such a weird
phenomenon I'm sorry in your 40s and 50s
even in your late 30s you are not
supposed to act like the women in their
20s you were supposed to mature like you
you're not supposed to be doing the same
things and I'll see these women in their
40s on Tik Tok I'm just like I think you
should be banned off social media over a
certain age yes especially if you're
just bitching about your husband get off
of there get off it is now is not the
time I'm sorry to say this Paul but the
competition out there is really fierce
in the age of Tinder women are able to
attract younger guys no problem because
they can use technology to access those
guys from younger Generations my
thinking is they don't even want sex all
that much but what they really want is
having power over a male because his
little head is still overpowering his
big head he's still thinking with Mr
Winky and not with Mr Big Brain so she's
confident he's not going anywhere
because he loves her I know I'm not
doing much to build your self-esteem and
self-confidence to go out there and
approach new women in their 30s but I
think it's important that you understand
the mentality of women out there these
days at this point money and Status will
also help you attract such women but
that also becomes harder and harder as
you get older I think at some point
you're going to have to go mtown monk
mode because you're not into escorts and
eventually you'll probably lose access
to the women of good breeding age this
happens to all guys and we need to
accept it sooner than later and simply
move on with life as men we enter middle
age and we want to pretend that our
sexual prow continues but what it's
really doing is regressing and we can't
stop this unfortunately when you're in
your late 40s and looking for women in
their 30s people start looking at you
like a creepy old man but for women it's
often quite different when they can
still crack open a 20-some year old yo
and this is the thing if a girl goes if
she's 45 she dat Madonna everybody
celebrates Madonna going after the 20
something 30s something year old man but
when what's his face um that 79-year-old
impregnated a 30-year-old what what was
the I can't remember you know what I'm
talking about the yeah alpacino when he
got when he was 70 9 getting a
29-year-old pregn pregnant I had people
tell me that the woman was being used
and that she was like being prayed upon
I'm like how does a 29-year-old get
prayed upon I'm sorry I'll give you guys
16 I'll give you I I still kind of
think you know what you're doing at 16
but whatever whatever we'll go up to 18
the legal age you're telling me this
woman has been legal for a decade over a
decade and she's been prayed upon what
about her praying upon him for his m
money what about what what about her
maybe she's predatory I mean it's
like we we talk about the men praying on
the women but we don't talk about the
women praying on the men they use their
beauty you don't think that's some form
of Leverage oh no oh no poor me I got
pre impregnated by a multi-millionaire
at 29 I just I I can't do it I can't I
can't I have zero sympathy no no no no
29 how are you pray prayed upon like
that's what you use for a kid oh my gosh
and they're in their 40s but Madonna
does it and it's cool Madonna does it
and everybody cheers her on it's like
what the basically now hailed as a fine
piece of hero ass anyways for the rest
of this video I want to be discussing
other traits that I've noticed in women
over the age of 40 once women had
menopause decreasing hormone levels mean
that they get extreme anger anxiety
depression and overall lack of
self-confidence oh my God that makes so
much sense also women in their mid to
late 40s lose interest in sex almost
almost entirely for the act itself
someone recently posted on my channel
that in their late teens and up until
the age of 25 women want sex all the
time and I found that was pretty much
true but once they get into their mid to
late 20s they want less and less and
they start resenting having sex but once
they get in their 30s they actually want
sex again but not because they want to
but because they actually want to use it
to catch a man but then after squeezing
one out most women will never really
want sex again in any great quantity if
you missed the boat as a man having sex
with women while you were in your late
teens and early 20s
then you'll never really know what true
female desire is like it is great but
it's not meant to last and it disappears
and then it's gone forever so Paul maybe
and that's what they don't talk about
predatory women there are absolutely
predatory women um we we we know there's
pred because everyone will be like but
what about the predatory men we know we
talk about the predatory men all the
time they never talk about predatory
women that use sex as a weapon to get a
guy and then completely switch up after
they get into a contract that Legally
Legally binds them to the guy and they
compl and men talk about this all the
time they'll get married and say my wife
completely switched up on me after I got
married she got so fat after we got
married it's like now that she's legally
stuck to you now you got to switch up
that's what the chicks do want you to
feel good about letting go of this phase
of your life because those women in
their 30s probably want to have sex with
you because they wanted to land you and
keep you you're probably not a doctor
lawyer actor or Banker because in those
professions your utility value often
losts until you're in your 70s and ' 80s
so those women in their 30 will often
try to lock you in a good example of
this is Patrick Stewart he's married to
a woman that's 38 years of age do you
really think that she would be with him
if she didn't get all that attention
when the two of them walked down the
street or if he didn't have all that
money a man with status and money is
absolutely irresistible to women in any
age but because this man has money and
status and he's older and his Sex Drive
is probably so low she doesn't even have
to yank his pigtail all that often but
even a woman like her is probably going
to be getting hot flashes in less than a
decade he's also probably just waiting
for some captain and peard Widow money
to roll in by then so she's certainly
going to be living long and prospering
in the future I just want everyone out
there to understand that when a woman
enters her 40s because of hormonal
changes all the bad quality she had
pretty much get Amplified that's why as
women age they get bitchier and bitchier
and you the man lose your testosterone
so you lose the ability to stand up to
the insanity the two no way that's so
crazy so basically when a woman hits
metapa she gets crazier and the men have
less of an ability to fight it because
they lose their testosterone which Ben's
testosterone levels already crazy low
nowadays anyways you're going in
completely opposite directions you're
slowly turning into a neutered indoor
house cat while she's turning into an
angry 5-year-old brat the kind that M
all right all right an angry 5-year-old
okay all right cats for fun what else
could go wrong as a man in his middle
age I would suggest that you do whatever
you can to keep your testosterone level
high as well you can boost it 20% right
away by staying away from long-term
relationships ships exercise so long as
you don't overdo it for your heart by
doing things like push-ups and crunches
also reduce your stress take vitamin D
and also lose weight will all pretty
much bring your testosterone up I'm not
an expert in this but I say that if you
can boost your testosterone then you can
actually think on your feet around women
I'll probably make a video at some point
about how to actually boost a man's
testosterone we have seen the steady
decline in testosterone levels and sperm
levels in men all across the world in
the last few decades when this happens
we become less and less able to deal
with women and men become cucks it's
scientifically proven that a man's
testosterone level drops by 20% when
he's in a relationship and there's also
been a no way have you have you noticed
being do men notice when the
testosterone levels drop have you you
know your that's what they're saying
your testosterone levels drop by 20% in
a relationship you notice that yeah wait
that's why I always want to get out of
the
house that's why they like hide from us
they they'll call it man cave like to
get away from us or like boys traps
they're like I need to get away from the
women 20% drop in testin and then we're
such too we'll be like no why do
you want to be away from us from other
factors so that means that a man going
his own way today and not oh my god I've
done that before longterm relationship
why can't we come same amount of
testosterone that a man had in a
relationship about a generation ago that
explains why men don't seem to have the
ability to stand up to women anymore
because men have the testosterone of
teenage boys instead of the testosterone
of fully grown men women also have a lot
more estrogen in their system and as a
result are menstrating a lot sooner and
actually are far more Moody I remember
telling my ex-girlfriend years ago to
stop drinking from plastic water bottles
so that her PMS wouldn't be as bad and I
was absolutely right the moment she
stopped drinking from them and replaced
them with glass water bottles her mood
was a lot less you're telling me
these water bottles make me what
what they said they said water bottles
up your hormones I guess that's
what they're saying and the PMS was gone
but that too is a story for another day
anyways that's all I've got to say for
today thanks again Paul for your
donation as well as your topic don't
forget this I really like bottle but I
heard that the water in the in the sink
is like terrible too like something I
heard everything's just I I got I did an
interview with Alex Jones recently and
they're telling he's telling me
everything's in like you drink the water
from the faucet it's bad I drink it from
the bottle it's bad yeah you almost
can't run away from it anymore there's
microplastics in almost everything now
and I heard our birth control it's also
like ruining everything I've just heard
a lot like button and check out the
mtown mystery link as for everyone else
out there please follow me on Twitter or
like me on so guys I really think the
mgtow guys get a bad rep I really do I
really think they're just some really
logical guys that have just decided that
the average chick isn't worth dealing
with anymore now I know you guys will
you'll you'll clown them and dog them
but I don't know if you guys had done
some of the interviews I've done with
men that have been wrecked by divorce
child support you know I I understand
from a logical point of view why they
want to walk away from the average chick
you know and I don't say this you know
when I first thought I was triggered a
bit too cuz I was like why would you
want to walk away from women that's a
bit rude but you know then you start
looking at the stats you know where one
out of four women as an STD one out of
Three's had an abortion 90% have been on
birth control the average chick has
slept with over you know and the numbers
you guys will argue with me on these
numbers night and day the average chick
has slept with over um between five and
eight men and everyone thinks it's more
like 30 so you know I don't know but the
point is you're you're essentially
ruined from Pair bonding with a husband
after like 5 to8 so you know guys look
at these numbers they look at the system
that they have to get married into and
they think you know I'm just going to
walk away now I'm not saying that's good
for families I'm not saying that's good
for society but I I think the mtow guys
get a bad rep I really think they do I
don't think there is they're categorized
the way that a lot of people you know
categorize them just my opinion but you
know maybe I'm wrong let me know what
you think in the comments you know like
the video that's the most important
metric YouTube uses to push out these
streams leave a comment for what I
should react to next subscribe and I'll
talk to you next time